un quatorzième et dernier vendredi à
manifester
ils en ont marché des kilomètres depuis
février est moins grave de ce type en
janvier
ça me l'espoir parce que ça montre que
je suis pas le seul dans le clutch pin
le destin collectif
ça montre que la jeunesse croit en
quelque chose dans votre cuisine est il
conscient de son pouvoir d'action c'est
pour l'humanité mais surtout pour leur
génération qu'ils descendent dans la rue
on s'inquiète pour notre futur pie on
veut nous autres aussi profiter de ce
que les gens sont en train de bâtir
aujourd'hui oui ça sert à quelque chose
bâtir notre économie mais si après on
peut pas l'utiliser plus tard dans un
avenir ça sert à quoi ils demandent
l'abandon total des énergies fossiles
l'adoption d'une loi climatique ils en
ont ras-le-bol de l'inaction des
gouvernements la société civile au
complet monsieur legault monsieur
trudeau vous demande d'âge et c'est
maintenant que ça se passe
la preuve de l'abandon du gouvernement
selon et c'est cette question de
l'épreuve de français de cinquième
secondaire
peut-on s'adapter au changement
climatique une question qui a suscité
l'indignation des élèves qui ont à leur
tour soumis un coup et au premier
ministre
quelles actions le québec devrait-il
causé pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques
le gouvernement va répondre et le
ministre charest ti notre vie nous le
dira mais seulement sur à vous répondre
avec le dépôt d'un plan global propos
lui permet de baisser les bras
en attendant ce plan les jeunes
promettent d'être de retour dès la
rentrée scolaire en septembre prochain
ici sébastien desrosiers radio-canada
mourir
[Applaudissements]